The last feature of this visualization I want to cover is animation.
Animation isn't technically a visual encoding, but
you can think of it as encoding some information, or rather,
change of information in a certain sort of way.
As we can see here,
the animation really highlights how drastically different the Facebook IPO
was in value compared to the history of IPOs that came before it.
Not only does the animation convey some of the process the RS went through
in creating this visualization, such as discovering that the Facebook IPO was so
drastically greater than all the other IPOs.
Or the fact that using different scaling, in this case logarithmic,
makes the graphic much more interpretable, but also gets across
some of the relative change of the companies in the years after they've IPOed.
While you might be able to encode this sort of information, such as how much
a company's value has changed after its IPO, in another dimension of visual
encoding, let's say the z axis, it is much easier, and I think
much more effective, to communicate that information through the animation.